Hình đồng sắp có bảo xun năm, cưng đội mạnh dật cấp mi hai.
Tha chúng tâm dự bảo khi tự thuyván quốc gia cho biết,
hiện nay ở khu bực phía đồng phía lip có một át thất nghiệt lời đặc hoạt động.
Hồi mệt sảo dự ngày 20 tháng mời,
phía chỉ tâm át thất nghiệt lối vào khoảng viết ra phía năm đội biber,
một chăm bà viên mốt phía không đội kinh đồng.
Cái đảo lúc dồng phía lip còn một nhiên bà trong kilomét phía phía đồng năm,
sức giống lại nhất của gần tâm át thất nghiệt lối, mạnh cấp mời.
Năm hơi để xam mức mốt kilomét chân dơ,
sật cấp chiến, sức bảo xung hai mệt lối tối,
át thất nghiệt lối dịch chuyển chủ yếu thêm buông tay tế bác
có khả năng mạnh liên thành bảo.
Lến mời sảo dự ngày nay,
việc gí tâm báo ở vào khoảng mi muốn phía tâm đội biber,
một chăm hai niệm bệm mốt đội kinh đồng,
trên đường biển phía đồng phía lip.
Sức giống mạnh nhất của gần tâm bảo mạnh cấp tâm,
sống hi hai đến bệm liên làm kilomét chân dơ,
sật cấp mi một.
Sống biển cao tự bà đến buông mét,
đăng chui, chúng ta mừng dự bảo khi tâm ký bán cuốc gia dự báo,
khoảng mi hành mi lâm tháng mời bảo kho khó khăn năng dị truyền vào biển đồng.
Y vậy, đầy sẽ là cần bảo số 5 trinh biển đồng trong năm nay.